[Music]
the Democrats really don't want that why
is it that Democrats really want
everybody in public schools where they
learn about wokism and they learn that
boys or girls and chopping off your
genitals is good and they are
indoctrinated with things like the 1619
project and everything else this seems
to be happening in every
blue state that there is and here is
Katie Hobbs Katie Hobbs is the Democrat
Governor of Arizona and here she is
she's being asked the question about why
she doesn't support school choice choice
is good right I thought the Democrats
are supposed to be pro-choice but here
she is being asked why doesn't she
support school choice and she kind of
doesn't really get to do much of
anything here take a look to play
something that the State House Majority
Leader said in response to your plan I
think this was his response to your
State of the State address okay
we also think it's only right that
Arizona students have the same choice
that Governor Hobbs had attending a
private school which she credit
for helping her build a better life a
reference there to the private Catholic
High School that you went to so why
shouldn't all students have a chance at
what you said was so important in your
own life look I grew up in a
working-class family this was well
before any of this um of Public
Assistance for private school existed
and my parents made that choice I begged
them to send me to public school and we
sacrificed a lot there were times in my
family that we were on food stamps
um and so it wasn't it was a choice that
they made
um and they struggled to to make that
choice
um what I want is for every public every
student in the state of Arizona no
matter where they live to have access to
high quality public education and with
this Universal voucher system that's not
happening but if their system is failing
if their public school is failing no to
giving them a chance to go somewhere
else like you did
the the schools are failing because we
are failing to invest in them I actually
feel bad for Carrie Lake uh the fact
that carry Lake lost to that woman is
deeply depressing and she also does that
thing where you talk like this at the
end of every sentence so you don't
really have to say anything because
you're talking like this so then people
are like oh my God they talk like that
so they're obviously okay
um so you understand her parents did
everything they could if they were on
food stamps apparently but they somehow
could scraggle enough change to get her
out of the public school system because
they obviously were worried about the
public schools so they did everything
they could while they were eating their
little TV dinners uh and they sent her
to private school but she does not want
to give that opportunity to other people
[Music]
thank you